[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je vous remercie d'être tous
tous ici aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe
on produit on consomme on jette
hier on produisait ont consommé et ont
jeté et je suis sûr que même dans la
salle il ya des gens qui jettent sans
avoir consommé est ce que je me trompe
m&a voilà donc il faut qu'on arrête le
gaspillage non mais c'est drôle mais
c'est dramatique a quitté le côté obscur
quoi rejoignez la force claire et fait
des efforts donc c'est mon sujet
aujourd'hui donc je me demande pourquoi
on doit gaspiller de l'énergie sans
arrêt à les extraire des produits pour
ensuite les jeter à la poubelle
est ce que c'est un modèle qui
fonctionne non on a essayé on a vu ça ne
marche pas et nos poubelles débordent
donc maintenant il faut savoir ce qu'il
faut en faire donc c'est à ce moment là
dedans on est au 21ème siècle et c'est
comme ça qu'est né de recyclage ou life
cycling alors qui sait ce que c'est
exactement le recyclage merci pour les
réponses c'est sympa super donc en bref
de recyclage c'est le traitement des
déchets c'est le traitement des déchets
récupérés afin de les réintroduire dans
le cycle de production
après traitement ok pour alors en
refaire quelque chose
la même chose comme par exemple si on
prend je vais vous donner un exemple on
prend des bouteilles qui sont usagers on
les traite pour refaire des nouvelles
bouteilles mais on peut également avoir
des bocaux ou d'hiver avec lesquels on
va faire des verts pour boire c'est
clair pour tout le monde
voilà ok alors ça c'est le côté très
plus industrielle des usines et tout
ensuite moi j'ai une autre définition de
bay cycling pour moi c'est le côté un
peu plus g
on fait des trucs un petit peu plus
sympathique donc on peut faire du mobile
des bijoux on peut même faire des
vêtements c'est une façon écoresponsable
de s'habiller de se faire belle pour
vous mesdames pour vous messieurs aussi
voilà bon c'est pas facile mais on va y
aller donc par exemple dans le meuble
cycling ou de recyclage tout le monde
connaît des palettes
il ya eu à un moment donné la folie des
palettes où tout le monde voulait faire
des meubles en palettes y en avait par
ici par hasard
voilà un exemple de cycling ok donc
maintenant pourquoi est il nécessaire de
recycler aujourd'hui ça c'est la vraie
question avant de recyclage où tous les
petits bricolages et et la pâte à papier
des trucs qu'on fait pour les
anniversaires mais aujourd'hui ça
devient un réel problème qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire de nos déchets on va des
maîtres on abat des maîtres chez le
voisin en douce la news j'en ai trop ont
des plans par ici où on les envoie
quelque part non franchement c'est un
véritable problème et pour ça il faut
trouver des solutions
alors il y à quelques chiffres qui sont
assez effrayant alors je vais vous dire
il ya 50 tonnes de plastique sont
produits dans le monde
à chaque seconde c'est quand même
effrayant 12,5 tonnes de papier sont
consommés à chaque seconde dans le monde
ok dans le monde deux arbres alors et si
vous le c là on va le savoir
donc dans le monde on a un arbre sur
cinq est abattu pour l'industrie
papetière il faut savoir que de batié
c'est mon matériau de prédilection parce
qu'ici on a beaucoup parlé on parle
beaucoup du plastique maintenant etc
mais on a oublié a oublié de papier il
est vrai que pour les arbres on trouve
de plus en plus de solutions
mais c'est quand même un matériau qu'on
trouve un peu partout c'est quelque
chose qu'on trouve absolument barton
parce que ça s'est démocratisée tout le
monde ya accès alors un million de dhs
arbres représentent des impressions
inutiles des entreprises
est-ce que vous rendez compte de ça ça
veut dire qu'on est au bureau on fait
une photocopie octobre on jette on va en
faire une autre et ça fait 1 million de
darbres 1 c'est quand même effrayant
donc 80% des déchets qu'on à vienne des
emballages on achète à chaque fonds mais
des trucs dans les malles château et
finalement on se retrouve encore avec
plein d'emballage hockey est là et 40 ou
80 % des déchets qui a dans nos
poubelles ce sont aussi des emballages
que ce soit au bureau donc maintenant il
faut qu'on arrête
pourquoi il faut recycler savez vous à
quoi est égale une tonne de papier
recyclé c'est d'égal à 3 à 5 tonnes de
bois économiser c'est la quantité de co2
dégagée par une voiture sur 1000 km ça
correspond à deux fois moins d'eau et
quatre fois moins d'énergie dépensée
donc est ce que vous comprenez pourquoi
il faut recycler voilà j'ai pris un
exemple de sur le papier mais je trouve
que les chiffres sont assez effrayant
bon donc maintenant il est urgent que
l'on trouve des solutions ça chacun à
son niveau je suis pas dieu mais je
pense que c'est tous ensemble qu'on peut
trouver des solutions et chacun peut
agir à son niveau
parce que recycler c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est facile n'est-ce
pas bon alors maintenant recycler les
métaux on trouve que c'est rentable
parce que ça rapporte de l'argent
le plastique beaucoup mieux - le plat le
papier on n'en parle pas trop parce que
avec la catastrophe écologique due à la
déforestation
on a dû vraiment tapé du poing sur la
table et donc il y à des efforts qui ont
été faits mais tout ce qui a été fait
n'est pas suffisant
la planète déborde et on continue à
gaspiller
nous sommes toujours du côté obscur de
la force
donc je ris mais c'est pas vraiment
drôle
alors maintenant qu'elles sont des
intérêts du recyclage et comment arriver
vers un monde avait plus durable c'est
la question je vous le demande parce que
moi je sais pas non plus mais tout le
monde essaye de trouver des solutions
alors quand je vous parlais aussi du
papier alors tout le monde connaît le
papier est ce que il ya des gens qui
peuvent me dire à quoi sert de papier d
usage utilitaire du papier ou damart
vous commencez même pas pour des billets
de banque à les billets de banque
c'est le côté utilitaire ensuite qu'est
ce qu'on a encore quelqu'un peut me dire
les livres ensuite est-ce que ces
utilitaires des emballages sa peau du
don contre don 10 des billets de banque
sont utilitaires nous avons aussi des
autres usages qui sont décoratifs c'est
à dire dès qu on peut dire de papier on
peut dire de papier à lettres et cetera
et cetera
donc moi ce que je voudrais que vous
fassiez c'est avoir un nouveau regard
sur les déchets c'est ce que je voudrais
que tout le monde fasse parce que quand
on regarde un peu nos poubelles c'est
important on peut faire des tas de
choses avec ça et qui sait ce qu'il ya
dans sa poubelle
qu'est ce qu'on trouve qu est ce qu il
ya dans vos poubelles pardon qu'elle
emballages en bus le plastique et puis
le vert merci on trouve aussi du fer
débile et c'est alors il faut savoir
qu'avec tout ça bon il ya des déchets
qui sont recyclables
d'autres qui le sont il y en a qui coûte
très cher à recycler il y en a d'autres
qui sont un peu moins coûteux et ça
c'est toujours le problème entre
l'industrie et d'écologie parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas toujours à se mettre
d'accord ce qui rapporte pas trop au
commerce
on y fait un peu moins attention ok donc
maintenant je vais vous développez
pourquoi recycler le papier
voilà donc moi j'ai travaillé à non mais
avec des prisonniers j'ai formé des
prisonniers j'aurais appris à fabriquer
des objets à partir de matériaux
recyclés et cet argent à des beurres
servir plus tard il allait vendre d'art
objets et cet argent à des leur servir à
la sortie des prisons pour qu'ils aient
un petit revenu et je vois que chaque
fois on essaye de recycler ont montré
aux gens des possibilités qui existent
avec le recyclage
ils font des efforts et automatiquement
une chaîne solidaire autour même à
l'intérieur de la prison les gens ont
commencé à recruter ont amené des
canettes enfin les cartons d emballage
etc
au tchad j'ai formé des instituteurs
parce qu'il ya des écoles de quartier ou
franchement il n'y a absolument rien
mais même pas une table les enfants sont
par terre donc ce sont des instituteurs
qui sont livrés à eux mêmes dans les
quartiers ils n'ont aucun matériel ils
peuvent demander et rien ne se passe si
on attend que tout tombe du ciel
rien ne va arriver on peut demander ça
ne viendra pas donc j'ai essayé de leur
apprendre à fabriquer du matériel
éducatif pour les enfants et ainsi
chaque école a fabriqué une box à partir
de matériel recyclé des jeux des
abécédaires enfin tout ce qui peut
servir à d'éducation et ensuite c'était
à leur tour d'apprendre aux autres et là
encore il ya toute une chaîne qui s'est
faite autour du recyclage parce qu'ils
ont vu et que je leur ai montré à quoi
pouvait servir tous des déchets qu'on a
dans les poubelles
voilà
donc au niveau d'éducation au niveau des
cols c'est important je pense aussi que
si on enseignait le recyclage aux
enfants dès le plus jeune âge ça
deviendrait un mode de vie un
automatisme parce qu'on ne montre pas si
on en montre des possibilités qui
existent investir dans les poubelles
quand j'enseignais à l'école pour les
arts créatifs aux enfants ils se sont
mis à recycler parce qu'ils savaient ils
disaient ah oui madame elle demandait ce
qu'on peut garder des rouleaux de papier
toilette est ce qu'on garde les cartons
de céréales etc
il ya toujours toute une chaîne qui se
développe autour et non aussi un autre
tour on peut faire des tas de choses
organiser des petites collectes dans
l'est dans les quartiers parce que si on
sait qu'on fait quelque chose des gens
se mobilisent on peut demander créer des
points on peut récupérer des choses à
recycler vous allez me dire on ne sait
pas recyclés etc
mais tout le monde sait le faire et
quand vous ne savez pas donner au lieu
de jeter chercher des gens à qui à qui
ça peut servir et des gens qui savent
s'en servir mais vous déjà votre niveau
à la maison vous pouvez le faire qui a
déjà jeté une chemise à personne jet de
chenilles si vous quand vous jetez la
chemise vous prenez la chemise et vous
l'a jeté à la poubelle
voilà ne serait-ce que retirer les
boutons sur cette chemise qui pourrait
servir à quelque chose c'est déjà faire
un geste parce qu'on pourra s'en
resservir pour quelque chose
vous jetez un pull odieux de jeter vous
pouvez détricoter il ya des gens qui
savent tricoter des grands-mères savard
servir à quelqu'un en fait ce que je
voudrais c'est que chaque fois que
quelqu'un veut jeter quelque chose qui
réfléchissent en se disant à quoi ça
pourrait bien servir maintenant alors je
vais vous montrer ce qu'il est possible
de faire vous voyez tout ça ce sont des
meubles en carton
c'est fait à partir de carton recyclé
que je récupère ou que des gens ou que
les gens maven voyez c'est quand même
pas compliqué donc on peut faire du
petit mobilier dépôt ça ce sont des
capsules de nespresso
parce que ça aussi ça devient un fléau 1
donc on peut faire des choses avec les
capsules nespresso
on veut également voilà alors ça c'est
de la tôle est ce que c'est la taule sur
les toits alors ça c'est de la taule
c'est une lutte qui est fait avec la
tôle
évidemment j'ai mis quelques exemples de
quelques photos pour vous montrer que
leur site à sa veut être glam et qu'on
peut faire des trucs vraiment vraiment
sympa alors notre poubelle a vraiment un
grand pouvoir
donc s'il vous plaît chaque fois que
vous voulez jeter essayer de réfléchir
en disant je jette ça mais à quoi ça
pourrait me servir et je voudrais bien
que pour l'afrique où on a des tas de
déchets on jette je vais dire les
papiers ça sert pas cambadélis ou
couillard non on peut faire autre chose
normale rigole ou les beignets on peut
le garder et arriver à faire des choses
très glamour belle ça peut aider des
gens à fabriquer du mobilier d'intérieur
une déco plutôt sympa des bijoux et tout
un tas de trucs
bon je ne vais pas m'étaler mais
j'espère que vous avez tous compris ce
que je voulais vous dire
mais avant de jeter s'il vous plaît vous
avez juste à réfléchir et regardez ce
que vous mettez dans votre poubelle si
vous vous en savez vous ne vous en
servez pas donné lieu à quelqu'un
d'autre
apprenons à nous servir de notre
poubelle avec générosité parce que on
lui donne à manger à la poubelle donc
maintenant essayons de faire aussi un nu
alors est-ce que abidjan ville durable
de ça vous dit aussi et ben voilà donc
et donc voilà donc des entreprises
d'abidjan etc sida peuvent organiser des
points de collecte au lieu de jeter de
papier garder le papier garder les
cartons etc pour que les gens récupèrent
et s'essaye je viendrai sans doute faire
des formations pour le papier ou le
carton et montrer comment on se sert de
tout ça en tout cas je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté et j'espère que vous avez
compris mon message merci